i auditioned for like the han solo movie
back in the day and yeah yeah
the end is inevitable maverick your kind
is headed for extinction
maybe so sorry
but not today
top gun maverick we should have seen it
by now but i'm sure it'll be worth it
how many times have you seen it i've
only seen i've seen
the final final cut once okay how many
times did you cry
it is a a very it's a it sneaks up on
you like it really sneaks up on you like
i
the problem is is anybody that knows me
like knows i
i i you know i'm an emotional guy like i
can tear up in movies
but in top gun your guard's down like if
marley and me
i went to marley me like not gonna cry
like put up your guard glenn
you know like you know what's gonna
happen top gun even though reading the
script
shooting the movie you sort of have your
guard down a little bit
but yeah it wasn't pretty like i did a
lot of did a lot of crying so uh
but it's awesome i mean the movie is the
movie is
one of the greatest
things i think i've ever seen it it has
every
every bit of why you make movies it's
exciting
it's adventurous it's romantic it's
funny and
you know it elevates the action and
the flying sequences and the characters
from the first one
in every way that um you know
when we went into it like the the margin
for error is so small and the target
is so small and to hit it feels really
really good
i've seen so many theories about your
character already and i've seen like the
same headline just written with
different
characters it's like the pink man is
this person's son
this person's son no i think it's this
person's son yeah
i've been sworn to secrecy in in so many
ways there's a uh
you know the the old line from the first
one is uh it's classified if uh
if i told you i'd have to kill you
there's there's been some threats so
i uh obviously those headlines i cannot
confirm or deny
any of them so uh you'll just have to
wait for july
2nd 2021 i think right your instructor
is one of the finest pilots this program
has ever produced
are you getting your pilot's pilot's
license because of that i already got it
you got it yeah tom gave me that to me
for me as my christmas uh
gift uh so i got to you know because he
he gets excited about anyone that's like
passionate about aviation
so that was a really really nice deal
but it is a certain it's a great level
of freedom whenever you
get to just sort of like pick up and fly
instead of just like
it's like when you first get your
driver's license as a teenager when
you're 16 like you can drive anywhere
you know um now i can fly around this
you know
around the country the state anywhere i
want to go was tom cruise technically
your instructor
well tom on top gun put together the
entire flight
regiment that we followed so
he basically said this is the amount of
hours
i want them to fly in the extra 300.
this is what i want them to learn on the
cessna right
instrumentation you know the physics of
the airplane how it all works
you know how you sort of call through
the radio all that sort of stuff uh talk
to atc
um uh and on the extra 300 that's where
we got
into like g-force training so that's
where you know in the f-18 you can pull
up
like really 7.5 is the load limit but
you're really you can hit like eight
and in the movie we're pulling
technically more than that so
in the extra it was just all about g
tolerance getting you know
getting to the point where you just keep
working up the g's so you don't black
out
when you're actually up there and then
the l39 is like uh it looks sort of you
know it's like an f18 trainer so it's
like really learning how to fly in
formation
at some of these high g's so that when
we're actually doing in the 18 we're
we're safe and we're not running into
each other
um and that you know when you're acting
that you're not passing out because that
doesn't look cool
um did you have so yeah so he puts the
whole thing
together for sure like he was he was the
flight instructor
that's cool so did you have to do that
thing where you go up and they like turn
off the engine and then they're like
figure out how to land it
oh yeah i mean by the way you'll see
this when you get your pilot's license i
mean it's just a it's a it's a stall
you know it's like you you you learn all
these like emergency procedures
in order to you know understand how much
time you have
if your engine does go out prop stalls
you hit a bird whatever it is
you know you have you have enough time
to sort of figure out how to get to an
airport and
you're aware you have enough like
situational awareness to like get to an
airport
and like you know bring yourself and
everybody else you know home safely so
um yeah it's interest it's interesting
the amount of knowledge like
usually from a movie when you research
something you come away from a movie
with like a weird bit of knowledge about
the world or
or an occupation or you know a type of
life
but on top gun like i came away with
like so much
random knowledge like just about like
the navy and the world like talking to
these admirals that have dinner with
admirals at night so i'm like talking
about world politics
and then you know then getting your
pilot's license and learning like the
physics of an airplane and
how to dog fight and how to get your
nose on somebody it's like it's it's
just weird
how i came away almost feeling like more
of like i was i like actually was in the
navy than an actor you know what i mean
like
that's crazy so you got like most of
your flight hours on top gun
isn't that crazy yeah yeah well that
that is the the cool part is like it's a
really rare experience like flying with
the best pilots in the world
and getting trained by the best pilots
in the world and also
when you know a flight instructor you
know is testing you on
all your knowledge and they look in your
logbook and you have f-18 hours
like they're very confused you know what
i mean like no civilian has f-18 hours
especially when you're
trying to get your pilot's license so
that was kind of cool so you're also
working with jd dillard on yes
a movie called devotion he's doing star
wars next apparently
you're circling all these star wars
people you got to put your name in the
hat
it's a really nice thing to say to me um
i would like that uh
we we can talk it out i mean look jd is
i'm getting we're sort of in
pre-production for devotion right now
which is you know jonathan majors who's
uh in lovecraft
is like who i'm a huge fan of and he's
just the greatest guy like we're
prepping for that right now and jd
he's been writing star wars so i've
gotten to be
privy to enough to understand that he's
gonna crush it
and he's just a brilliant mind um
and the star wars universe is a really
cool universe like i auditioned for like
the han solo movie back in the day and
yeah
yeah yeah probably not premiere i don't
think i knew that though
yeah well i'm just friends with like a
lot of those guys like chris and phil
and you know some of the some of the
guys over at lucas um
and but that was a really interesting
audition
that um because you know the part of the
audition
is um talking to chewie
right so so in the audition they play
like a dog
sound as chewy
right so you have to like interact with
this dog sound like
like what no i don't understand what
you're saying and oh and there's just a
casting director with like a dog
a dog button that was literally how you
were acting through your scenes
yeah if you ever felt like sort of a
talking prop you know you don't look
cool in audition by any means but
and then obviously i definitely didn't
because i didn't get it but
um i love those guys you know and that
it would be a really fun world to occupy
at some point
well i'm telling you it's gonna be great
when have i ever steered you wrong
there's a lot of roles that i could have
gotten that things would have been a
little different i'm glad i've kind of
taken the slow
slow path
[Music]